so haben alle zuließen folge lässt
megaprojekt essig china ganz noten
rechten ecke da sich den crafter in 92
meter entfernung hallo also bei mir
gerade ohne fans kam und alle die die
sich jetzt fragen und mit wem nämlich
heute auf mit sparkasse
also baten die autokorrektur ihren
mobilgeräten die sagt nummer sparkasse
wider erwarten gegen sus keeper dem muss
jetzt schlafen
naja dürftig konzentrieren der schon
letzte folge mit ihr aufgenommen du hast
jetzt eben die kleinen schritt weiter
gemacht und in richtung elektro gegangen
das heißt dass jetzt die grundlagen wie
major extraklasse ganze zeug genau also
ich hab gefragt wie soll ich mir energie
holen und so hat mich damit von kämpfen
bisschen beraten lassen denn natürlich
jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr in die
richtung vize scheiße geht auf mit der
scheiße ist club explodierten
direkt neben sechs plätze grundstücke
vor dass er wieder auf scheiße das hat
wegen dem lenker das nicht geklappt
damals neue gleich baum düsseldorf
also ich werde auch in die richtung
solarpanel gehen wollte erst wasserkraft
machen allerdings habe ich das bike es
gesehen der hat zwar eine menge energie
allerdings meinte cap auch dass der
wahrscheinlich in zukunft das ganze noch
höher ziehen muss ganz einfach aufgrund
der tatsache war dass bei dem doch
zurzeit ein bisschen weniger energie und
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich komm
einfach ganz viele solarpanel packt die
da oben drauf bz was machen wolltet
solar level
panel kann ich mal kurz die einen jeden
solarpanel da low voltage brauche ich
nämlich acht solarpanel 1 habe ich schon
das heißt noch sieben lv transformator
der geht aber relativ einfach und das
wollte ich jetzt erstmal machen den
nächsten folgen und da bei solchen
sachen das ist immer ganz witzig wenn
man sich dann andere leute suchte damit
dem aufnehmen zum beispiel gleich neben
auch noch eine folge mit kommissar
roddick auf was dann wahrscheinlich auch
sehr witzig werden wird weil zuwenig
jetzt sehr lange schon nicht mehr
aufgenommen hat und sollen wenigsten
bisher hat mit lukas zusammen diego ich
hab gestern mit dem nachfolger aufkommen
ich habe es geschafft ihn wohl ein
bisschen zu motivieren
interessanterweise ich habe mir dachte
springt vielleicht nochmals im nicht
genießen nicht so ganz gelegen hat das
thema an sich deshalb na ja er war als
fan gehen übrigens nebenbei erwarte ich
baue in ganz kurzer block ab ich lag
schon im bett in die komischerweise
immer wenn ich mit ihr aufnehmen
verringert sich die lautstärke von
meinem minecraft im moment das heißt sie
muss auf 100% geräusche gehen und ich
bin du es trotzdem noch viel lauter als
das spiel einfach zu halten wenn ich
wenn ich mit cap aufnehme dann hab ich
minecraft auf 20% lautstärke dass es
perfekt das ist super aufeinander
abgestimmt aber mitleid oder das einfach
ignoriert das nicht so leise sondern du
bist zu laut ich habe das mikrofon auf
die niedrigste einstellen die
hingekriegt habe ich habe das gern
funktion aufs minimum zurück gestellt
wenn ich jetzt hier acht neun ganz
kurzfristig tram dreh und trainiere
werde ich lauter lauter lauter aber dass
wir nicht machen
die lauterer schlechtere qualität das
ist das ist ja nur der pegel du musst
dein ding sehr lauter machen deine grund
laut steck vom mikrofon
wenn ich die konzertreihe ich bin auf
dem weg was du machst ist der pegel wenn
ich das jetzt machen würde wird sich
will ich mich nachher zeit einfach so
anhören dass auch total schrecklich
einfach so ländlichen oder welche person
du liegst schon längst im bett ich schon
seit 1 minute warten weg war da
also etwas willst du jetzt machen in
dieser folge ich bin gerade dabei mein
haus zu bauen an liebeskunst schon mal
eigentlich so ziemlich fast fertig hat
sich so viel verändert bis auf dem
grundstück jährigen fraktionen
äußerlichen bauten gleich kommen leute
vorbei und schauen dass wir morgen
mussten angucken
ich habe meine energieproduktion
bisschen umgelegt die wird später auch
weiter umgelegt das will ich auch machen
konstanz wahrscheinlich auch gleich da
müssen wir noch mal schauen also im
wesentlichen bis nicht das haus gerade
um sich ich hab das schon mal ein
bisschen ford wollte ich weiß was wohin
muss deshalb brauche ich schon mal das
haus und alles im weg steht bei karmann
bogen um das kann später noch ergänzen
ich finde mein haus ruft das mir zur
kugel cloud wurde von irgendwem als eine
kugel zwei kühe von mir sind weg ich
sagen ich weiß ganz anders wie gummi
bäume geklauter statement auf der wiese
also hinter meinem haus finden war habe
ich so einen ganzen haufen weiß vom
gummibaum hingestellt
naja ich hab damit etwas abgeschlagen
aber auch nicht alles ach so guten aber
da war sind gewonnen lassen abbau habe
ich es nie komplett gut ich meine es ist
ja legal weil es in meinem grundstück
ist ich hab nur ein bisschen habe ich
auch etwas abgebaut ich habe schon
gedacht dass das ihnen denn da hier
gebaut hat deswegen will ich jetzt nicht
abbauen diese hat mir kraft gegeben für
die robert riesch hat den rabatt wie
fällt das ist allerdings in puncto meter
von hier weg und auch in die richtung
der von surprise grundstück allerdings
hatte ich da kein habe ich dann kämpfte
frage welche leihen kann man bringe ich
die irgendwann wieder zurück einfach
aber nie das bei dir war ich nicht das
okay ohne klar selbst wenn sie
mitgenommen hätte wäre es okay gewesen
weil es ähnlich laufen grundstück
gewesen wäre so ja dicke am baum richtig
dicke werde genau überlegen wenn man
stein in einem extra-raum sand draußen
macht also ich hab momentan auch genug
energie
energie habe ich zurzeit noch nicht
genug also mein jetpack ist vor dass du
schon mal ganz gut
das kann ich euch gleich mal
demonstrieren meiner lieben freund ich
bin damit wollen ja schon geflogen
man kriegt aber fall schaden damit das
findet ein bisschen blöd deswegen ich
wollte mir solche schuhe machen muss man
keinen fall schaden kommt ja sie noch
bei sich diese schuhe diamant mir
verraten
vier diamanten brauchst du dafür wann wo
habt ihr alle eure 1000 jemand näher
hier frage ich mich das wo hast du deine
ganzen diamanten her aus der erde
ich habe 46 knapp tut mir leid aber du
hast mit zauber angefangen jeder kriegt
man das relativ schnell dann ja was
heißt ja wie schnell dazu eine
verzauberte spitzhacke mit der kann man
unter durch die wände kuchen halten an
schnell zählt kann solche wende gucken
ob da jemand anders oder weisen anders
ich habe schon gedacht dass ich mit der
spitzhacke jetzt enchanted ich weiß
nicht ob ich das machen soll
vor allem mobil spitzhacken am besten
ist wenn ich diesen diamondbacks
verzauberung wäre ja dann glück drauf
kriegen egal ich heute erst mal ganz nah
glück habe ich leider verloren als
gestorben bin bei dir mit dir du bist
schuld ja ich bin schuldig bin auch
gestorben
ja okay wer oder weniger aus
die übrigens so große mein gesamtes
hausausweise großes grundstück das heißt
es im gesamten harz großmann gesamtschau
bei dir hier hakt einmal ungemein ich
weiß nicht wieso ich habe hier nichts
ich habe wirklich nichts
ich habe hier unter 2 hühnchen drin ich
habe die ganze mission dezimiert ach du
du betreibst die du machst die ganze
soll ab jetzt einfach nebeneinander und
betreibt damit dann
ich habe eine großflächige solaranlage
ich habe drei boxen wo insgesamt
zusammen rund 20.000 energie gespeichert
wird
diesen machst du dir nicht noch drei
solarpanels mitnimmst machte dann low
voltage denkt weil ich für die drei
weiteren zwar fans nochmal körper
braucht es erst mal holen genau beim
zaubern das kannst du mir mal jemand bei
bringt das würde ich dir schenken oder
so das wäre ungemein endet von dir wenn
du willst du alles was ich brauche was
hast du brauchst prinzip nur anfang der
rest von selbst ist es wirklich forschen
einfach nur dass er jetzt komplett
selbst erklären eigentlich ja das macht
auch heute zu werden na gut ich muss mal
gucken bei den minimum scherben kannst
du tolle minimum stein machen der also
eines verhandeln kann hin und her was
ganz lustig ja ich muss erst mal von
einem grundstück runterkommen oder das
bei minecraft abstützt warum hat das
denn hier so lange sie nicht aber das
ist ja nicht nur bei mir so ich habe
jedoch nichts ich als ich ich kann dir
du bist ja ziemlich gewagte da jetzt
geht's ich meine die magie zeug legt
visiert nicht lange ich erhalte läuft
wieder flüssig alles gleich und englisch
ist da irgendwas oder wie oder wo ich
hab keine ahnung ich hoffe dass man
keinen dunst warum das um hakelt egal
ich habe jetzt auf jeden fall genug
energie meinem bett box okay ist es
jetzt möglich die reihenhaus einfach nur
zwischen zwei tanks oder so was weiß ich
kann auch sagen ich weiß nicht
jedenfalls sagt verlieren das ist fakt
ich habe jetzt nur 30.000 energie
allerdings reicht das reicht das für den
betrieb fernes land zu treiben
ja klar reicht das dafür dann werde ich
das jetzt erst mal ach ich hab meinen
stil noch bei käfer unten drin
da habe ich jetzt auf dem grundstück
mehr rausnehmen
wenn das schild draufsteht mit betreten
verboten nicht nee also jemand ich kann
das recht bei ihm reinlegen
ich weiß gar nicht ob jemand mich
einfach mal ganz kurz das 48 er betreibt
er hier echt so heftig bienenzucht ja
ich will dass man anfangs gar nicht wie
viel die anderen schritt voraus
aufgenommen ich bin jedenfalls eine
folge 56 grad beim frauen im voraus auf
einem genau das vor 56 30
du bist auch relativ schnell also ich
bin gerade voraus aufnehmen warte ich
kann man das gucken
ich bin dabei 32 und hochgeladen habe
ich bisher 17
also wenn man wenn man sich wirklich das
muss ich sagen das habe ich mich am
anfang ja 500 aber wenn man sich damit
beschäftigt und wenn man es dann auch
nach und nach versteht dann hat man
immer mehr bock auf die ganze sache
jetzt auf merck als würde ich gar keinen
bock drauf habe fast nur die gedacht
haben
also sind wir auch sieben folgen
verschollen das war ein bisschen doof
aber die folgenden e karte und daher
jetzt hab ich bock drauf und welches
jetzt auch im fernsehen nach und nach
durch die nur ich weiß nicht was man als
nächstes bauen soll
ich glaub ich werd ich das erstmal
zeigen hier ist klar es kommt ihren text
rein und raus generate das einfach der
gesetzlichen in chengdu der kann auch
energie rein machen in winterberg box
die gerade energie verliert weil hier
hängt ein extrakt daran und er
verbraucht natürlich bisschen an die
natürlich nicht sehr viel ist aber so
und allerdings ist das solarpanel an
deswegen kommt in die wertbons offenheit
gleich wieder direkt immer die rhein-
beziehungsweise währenddessen die ganze
zeit weil da dies ist die sonne scheint
ich nehme das mal ganz gut meint jetpack
und demonstriert dass
soso dann müsstest du aber auch durch
meinen helden portal durch langsame glos
soll braucht es dafür
ich hab noch los ich war doch im
gesamten komischen falle da hinten da
ist okay okay das kann bis er mich dann
ging's durch gelaufen weil ich bin
trotzdem durch den vorteil durch
laufwerk ist dadurch locker die wirklich
gefunden da muss ich mich da hinstellen
sony hat für roddick hat jemand ein
ernährer festung gefunden also dass
jemand so weit geflogen ist
ich glaube es war allgemein noch ist
erst recht wenige blätter und servonic
bewegen sich einfach gar nicht sie
stellen die auch wenn noch gar nicht
angefangen
jetzt bewegt er sich
ich weiß mein brot dahin
los doch nicht fax höher geklaut so ein
blog gibts einfach so mit jetpack weg
auch mit level 1 bin verzaubert sie
kriegen weil ich möchte einmal
bücherregal abbauen und den dann später
aber anders einsetzen zauber tisch
dadurch die bio regal wieder heisst
deuce
ich wollte mir auch daheim weil ich mir
machen weil wir gar nicht zuhört wie ich
ihnen was frage ist unglaublich doch ob
man mit level 1 stunden links genau da
steht dann hast du nicht geantwortet
einfach so daheim mit erzählt ich habe
gesagt weiß ich nicht denn ich wollte
euch natürlich wie immer zu so erwarten
wir wie hießen aber deine boots meine
schuhe jong foul boots von vorteil das
sind zwei verschiedene paar mal die
gleichen der eine wird du musst halt
erstmal zwar einzelne schule macht
wieder zusammen kräften doch den
stiftungs anziehen sagt steiner
massenhaft durchschmelzen christel
addiert ich glaube das mache ich auch
vielleicht für ein von kohlen 1
ich gehe farben runde und ich gucke mal
ob das funktioniert das ja von
zauberstab aber auch experience krieg
ich brauche mich kohle 100 mal ich kann
die mädels zu machen
mein koalitions farben zu fahren
ich gucke mal dass wir in den amboss
blaue dann verzaubert werden
ach das sind vier eisen und drei eisen
preise quasi reisen sechs batterien ein
team electronics circuit 33 egal ich
müsste eigentlich mal hier so ich war
noch was anderes machen sich gerade
minimum steiner kann auch mal zurück was
kann ich noch machen
william stein genau shapes kräften kann
so verschiedenes zeug machen der
kanadische gold mit diamant fahrzeug
über zwei armbrüste warum habe ich mit
zwei gemacht
ich hab keine ahnung so ambos
kritisieren jetzt das hostel anders ich
habe bücher niebels viele bücher durch
sowas alles und ehrlichkeit 1 das erste
mit endlichkeit nochmal meine schwester
stattfinden der unendlichkeit heißt
heißt dauer das ist das wenn ich jetzt
auf dem halb kaputt schwert mache ich
quatsche möglichkeit als infiniti
das ist für ein bogen nach aktion
endlich pfeile schießen brauchst keine
pfeile meter
aufgrund der zuvor kaputt wir machen wir
neue jedermann bogenbau ich einfach
immer falsch abgebogen falsch abgebogen
und endlichkeit geht nicht danach
rückstoß unendlichkeit
was ist ein rückschluss 2 das auf dem
schwert rückschluss seien oft weg kann
es auf dem schwert machen ja
behutsamkeit 1 lassen dass das ist ich
glaube das ist quatsch
das könnte ich eigentlich gebrauchen
willst mir das verkaufen könnte ich dir
verkauft werden ich könnte dafür
tonnenweise übergeben habe ich auch
genug
ach stimmt der boss der diamanten für
deinen vollmuth ich glaube sogar dass
mehr diamanten als rocker oder ja also
es ist also ein so würdigte spendieren
für private sector einen diamanten krise
dafür aber sonst was mich zwar kein die
ja für ein 61 verzauberung
ich kann das wasser affinität geben das
brauche ich nicht brauche jedoch zeit
brauchst du übrigens eine folge wobei
das zweite spiel machen hier den katzen
dementsprechend acht okay das ist ja mal
mit den caps und damit auch mit ihm
direkt er ist karten dann dealen mit
nord das seht ihr bei der nächsten folge
genau und wie sie